bicycles are I don't know there's an art
to them there's a beauty to them and
there's this really interesting
interaction between the human body and
the bicycle I'm Johnny coast and I build
custom bicycles here I love it when
someone walks in and says I want this
type of bicycle go crazy
let's see what is my spiel when people
come here we fill out an order form and
we basically try to get down to what
kind of bicycle they want this guy is
going to have one two three lights on it
and I can get to the best components and
just match this person with what they
want you know his arm inseam torso his
weight is all considered in tubing
selection and frame geometry
my customers have been a range of people
from bike messenger who's spending their
settlement Echo's cycles to Wall
Streeters lawyers like these types of
folks well they want nice things leather
bar tape is very popular like the old
French builders they would shellac cloth
tape so I'm like putting on like ten
layers of shellac and I love putting
that stuff on bikes I actually recently
had my bike stolen so I'm rebuilding
myself a new bike I do get a lot of
people who say they don't want to ride
their bikes because it might get stolen
or damaged I mean the answer is you just
kind of have to take that chance or you
don't get to enjoy the thing and you
should be careful
feels good